your eyes cool right away.
King, I want
my queen back.
Don't get me wrong, Salifi is human. I'm going to
get you back. If you really
want her back.  Fight with me here. Take it
by force. You
can stop. Are you okay?
[Music] What are you going to do by taking
this
off? Are you going to stop them? There
are times when you have to deal with such uncouth men with your fists.  Well then, doesn't
Ilia understand that the
opponent is only a human king of the demons
? Well, that human brat understands it best too.
Still, he
can live in everything, not just the pope. Still,
can you pull it off
here?  If I pull back, I'll be the same as that person again.I'll
get nothing for a moment.